-We don't always
have enough time
to cover everything
in the recent news,
so here with a recap is one of
our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, you guys!
Things have been crazy!
Okay. First of all,
the "Cats" movie came out,
and people who love musicals
were like, "What?!"
And people who love cats
And everyone else
was like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
Then, I heard they were
in such a hurry to get it ou
by Christmas that they sent it
into theaters unfinished.
Now, you can tell if you'r
seeing the unfinished versio
because you can see
Judi Dench's hand.
And I was like, "What...
does it matter?"
These cats have
whole-ass human faces.
Don't nobody care about a hand
Give Judi Dench a pair of
mittens and get on with it
Then, I heard that Trump
was talking trash
about Greta Thunberg,
and I was like, "What?"
Of course he's gonna try
to rag on Greta Thunberg.
He hates children.
He tried to send
five children to prison
for a crime they didn't commit
He hates children!
He takes them away from
their families at the border
The man hates children.
He wouldn't even
help this child,
and he was home alone,
lost in New York.
[ Laughter ]
Then, Madame Tussauds wax museum
unveiled their new statue
of Nicki Minaj.
And I looked at that statu
and was like, "Whaaaat?"
[ Laughter ]
Who is that?
How could you mess up so badly
What picture did you use
as a reference?
One somebody drew?
Now, I can't help but notice
you got the face wrong
but the ass right?
[ Laughter ]
Who made this statue,
a 13-year-old boy?
This doesn't look like
Nicki Minaj.
It looks like the lady
who calls the cops
when you play Nicki Minaj
too loud.
[ Laughter ]
Then, I heard Rod Stewart
punched a bouncer,
and I was like, "Whaaat...
old singer is he?"
Is he this one?
And my friend was like no.
And then I was like,
"Is he this one?"
And my friend was like no.
Then I was like,
"Is he this one?"
And my friend was like yes
And I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ What, what what,
what what? ♪♪
♪♪ And you think I'm sexy
♪♪ Come on, sugar, let me what
[ Light laughter ]
It was very fun.
Then, I heard actress
Sharon Stone
was blocked on Bumble,
and I was like,
"What...is Bumble?"
Because I'm married.
Apparently, it's a dating app,
and people were reporting
her account as fake
because they couldn't believe it
was really Sharon Stone.
And I was like,
"What is Sharon Stone
doing on a dating app?"
There should be a dating app
where people sign up
to date Sharon Stone.
In fact, I'm gonna make one.
Try to date Sharon Stone
with the new dating app
Romancing the Stone.
[ Light laughter ]
With Romancing the Stone,
love's just
a Sharon Stone's throw away.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of famous blondes
put Rod Stewart back up.
I have another one.
♪♪ Forever what ♪♪
♪♪ For-ever what ♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
Then, everyone was talking about
how Dr. Phil's son
put his house up for sale,
and I was like,
"What? Who cares?"
But everyone was like,
"You got to look at it."
And I did,
and I was like, "What?!"
A person lives here?!"
Then, I saw that his house
had a wall of guns in it,
and I was like, "What?"
If you're a psychologist
and your son has a wall of guns,
you are a bad psychologist
[ Laughter ]
Hey, speaking of bad boys,
put Rod Stewart back up.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪ Have I told you lately
that I what what? ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Then, I saw Miss America,
Miss USA, and Miss Teen US
are all black women,
and I was like, "What, what?!"
Then, a black lady
won Miss Universe,
and I was like, "Whaaat?"
Then another lady won Miss World
and I was like, "What?"
See, white people?
We can have nice stuff, too.
It won't kill you.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I was so proud of them
Then I was like, "Wait. Is every
black woman a pageant winner
Am I a pageant winner?"
And then I checked,
and I am.
This has been
"Miss Late Night Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]